I feel kind of like a spotted owl
and because I were
all wimpy nondescript easily overlooked
non biting mosquito oh really what the
talk is about is can we look into the
past and sometimes the present and can
this tell us something about tomorrow
and it's really perspectives from
phylogenetics genomics and development
in the pitcher plant mosquito the joint
effort between Christina Holt offal and
myself we've worked together as
evolutionary partners for more years
than we're willing to admit and we'd
like to thank many colleagues both in
Oregon and at other universities around
the world and especially the national
science foundation that has been
extremely kind for many years I think
really to to bring it home that what is
the potential that could happen this
shows deaths from malaria in eastern
United States this is the main portion
of our study areas as part of the world
Chris and I are mainly interested in
evolution and temperate environments and
this shows deaths from malaria in 1870
primarily along the eastern seaboard and
up through the Mississippi River Valley
and you think well there's no very few
deaths from malaria there today but the
major vector of malaria is omnipresent
throughout this range and awfully
squadra maculatus so the potential is
there but uh to bring it back to bloat
climate change that really temperature
is having a direct effect on the non
biological systems of the earth this is
a picture of the Muir glacier in 1941
and 2004 and as you can see in the
intervening years that has receded all
the way up the valley this is due to the
direct effects of temperature melting
ice but as we like to point out animals
are not glaciers and we we have to ask
what are the environmental forces that
are driving the biological response to
climate change
the other way I like to put it is we're
beyond throwing the family cat in the
microwave and yelling global warming
that there are other factors at play
here abiotic consequences of climate
change we're getting warmer winters in
particular in Eastern North America
winters are warming faster than summers
this is leading to earlier Springs and
if you just saw with the tix they were
getting early development and even
winter development of the ticks later
onset of winters and longer growing
seasons these are still abiotic aspects
of climate change so now let's look at
some of the biotic consequences they've
been widely documented that there's been
a general northward expansion of species
ranges in the northern hemisphere and
earlier development and reproduction in
the spring with a later onset of
dormancy or migration in the fall these
are biotic responses to climate change
and will now bring in the principal
actor the pitcher plant mosquito y mis
smithy i hear is a female laying our
eggs in a pitcher plant leaf this is the
purple pitcher plant which extends from
Florida North the Labrador and west to
Saskatchewan and now even some sightings
in British Columbia the female dropped
her eggs from the air onto the water and
the leaves the larvae go through for
larval enstars pupate and regenerate the
life cycle the plan has evergreen leaves
this is an early summer plant that is in
bloom here are last year's leaves that
have persisted through winter all leaves
from early spring and leaves that are
just now opening and the mosquito
completes one to seven generations per
year depending upon the latitude you're
looking at this is the summer picture in
the winter all things look very
different there are evergreen leaves on
the plant the plant persists of the y
Amaya over winters is a larva in
diapause the diapause is initiated
maintained and terminated by photo
period
and we can ask since temperature has
been a very predominant theme in this
talk how important is temperatures an
anticipatory cue as compared with light
and we have put a probe a watchdog in a
single pitcher plant leaf and this
represents temperature inside of that
pitcher plant leaf throughout a whole
year taken every two hours as you can
see there is a seasonal pattern it's
warmer in the summer than it is in the
winter but there's a tremendous amount
of variation from day to day week to
week month to month we actually know
that they're going into diapause at this
locality about day 300 Oh Julian date
yeah there's a little cold snap here but
it's warm before and afterwards so
temperature is a pretty fuzzy Q on which
to bet your life this is a when to go
into diapause is a life-or-death
decision we superimpose day length over
this picture we can see that day length
is highly regular in fact the number of
hours of light per day today in New
Haven is the same as they were 10,000
years ago and will be 10,000 years in
the future climate change is not
affecting the rotation of the earth
about the Sun ah and it is not changing
day length day length remains a highly
reliable Q through evolutionary time and
if you were going to bet your life on a
seasonal Q on being able to anticipate
and prepare for the changing seasons
which you bet on temperature or light in
fact a wide variety of animals thousands
of species and animals in the temperate
zone rely upon day length to program
their seasonal activities all of these
animals are photo periodic they use the
length of day to program some aspect of
their seasonal life histories ranging
from rotifers to rodents I guess this
must be one of ho peas animals because
here's the ear tag how should response
to day length I said that
all of the animals we've been well maybe
all of the animals on the previous slide
live at temperate latitudes and they
exist over a wide variety of latitudes
how should the use of day length change
with latitude here we have day length
and Julian date of the year for a
southern locality along the Gulf of
Mexico and for Northern locality along
the Canadian border the decision to
enter diapause or continue development
is made in the late summer early fall
and that's blown up over here and I've
plotted the onset of winter at the
northern latitude and a southern
latitude and northern animal to go die
up in an entered diapause before winter
would use a switching day length or
critical photo period around 15 and
three-quarters hours of light per day a
southern animal would use a southern day
length and enter diapause a little over
12 hours of life per day so the
prediction is that the switching day
length or critical photo period should
increase with latitude and in why am I
smithy I this map shows our principal
collecting localities it's very nice the
pitcher plants or long live perennials
living for a century or more so we can
go back to specific localities and
harvest whatever population attributes
we want over a long period of time in
fact one of our original sites here in
Florida we've collected from the same
plant for over 30 years and what we find
is when we bring them into the
laboratory grow them through several
generations to minimize maternal field
effects and then determine the switching
day length we find there's an extremely
tight correlation with latitude in fact
the switching day length or critical
photo period and why Maya smithy I
tracks geography more closely than any
other known eco Geographic trait and we
also find that has a high heritability
all the way from point O seven 2.77
depending upon the population you're
looking at
okay I've said that light is important
that unless you're a foolish organism
and there probably are some out there Oh
father Darwin calls them home ah that
you're going to rely on day length to
program your seasonal development but
can we show that this really affects
fitness and the answer is we can because
here is a pitcher plant in the spring
there are no new leads on it all the
overwintering larvae are here in the
water-filled leaves of this carnivorous
plant for those of you who have a
ghoulish tendency you'll notice that all
the hairs here point downwards we bring
the whole plant into the laboratory and
we can rear why am I smithy I in its
natural microhabitat in fact we run our
experiments determining fitness by
feeding them freeze-dried drosophila to
mimic the natural prey capture cycle of
the host plant and we are blessed with
claim climate control rooms that are
computer driven and we can generate any
climate from the tropics to the Arctic
including light temperature and humidity
and we can unlike nature we can just
opposed either of those we can give a
Florida mosquito a Florida thermal year
including daily and annual temperature
cycle and give it the light cycle of
Maine just to play around with it and we
define fitness is the year-long cohort
replacement rate not just summer fitness
so we start out we program one of these
rooms for a continuous year and we start
out with an initial cohort of larvae
that we put into pitcher plant leaves
and that constitutes the first
generation of the first summer the long
days of summer promote continuous summer
generations until the short days of fall
induce a larval diapause they overwinter
as larvae in the leaves until the long
days of spring stimulate resume
development and we get the first gen
eration of the second summer the adults
come out lay eggs the eggs hatch and we
get a cohort of hatchlings 15 months
down the line from when we started and
fitness integrated through all four
seasons then is the number of hatchlings
after one year divided by the initial
cohort size this you get a sample size
of one every 15 months and we now can
play around with the thermal ear and the
photic year remember we're programming
daily and seasonal variation in
temperature to mimic to start with in
northern locality will say what happens
to fitness of northern localities due to
to climate change so we have to have a
control so we give the northern
population of northern thermal ear and
the northern photic here and we get a
baseline level of fitness the year-long
cohort replacement rate we now give it a
southern thermal year equivalent to a
hundred and eighty years of climate
change at its current rate that is not
imposed over evolutionary time that's
imposed instantaneously and we leave it
with its native northern photo gear and
we say what happens to fitness it
increases 47% so for why am I like many
other tempered organisms as ray Huey's
lab for other ectotherms as ray Huey's
lab has pointed out warmer is better now
we can test the effects of light because
we've established that this is a
thermally benign climate what happens
now if we give it the same thermally
benign climate but give it the photic
year of six degrees further south and
the answer is an eighty-eight percent
loss and fitness so that photo periodic
mistiming of seasonal development is
very lethal and it's the correct
interpretation of light not temperature
that matters
we've done some work we're saying okay a
lot of people working with climate
change assume everything is static but
evolutionarily everything isn't
necessarily static is their evolutionary
response I've said this is a highly
heritable trait what can we say about
the genetic architecture well I could go
on for that for a long time but we'll
show you some of our recent data with
QTL mapping that we've used the
geographic gradient to focus on three
populations Maine New Jersey and Alabama
the Y amaya spent the last glacial
maximum oppressed closely to the glacial
front and within the last 13 thousand
years has migrated to northern Maine we
know using this is ahmad to calibrate a
molecular clock we estimate that the
main and alabama populations are on the
order of 200,000 years separated in
evolutionary time we drew a male and a
female from these two populations grew
them through seven generations in the
lab to promote independent recomp free
recombination and then genotyped on the
order of 250 individuals according to
their critical photo period and used rad
tags as markers and developed a linkage
map and then QTL Matt four regions of
the y mi smithy I genome responsible for
the evolution of photo periodic response
over this gradient this shows the log
odds score and you can think of it as
the likelihood that a given region of
the genome here are y mis three
chromosomes as an indicator that a given
region of the genome the likelihood that
it contributes to the evolutionary
divergence of these two populations and
points over this line are considered
significant those below it are not
considered significant and what we see
here is regions on the second and
third chromosome as being scored is
important in the evolution of photo
periodic response between New Jersey and
main we now look at alabama vs maine and
much to our surprise we obtained a very
different map that this tells us that
it's three regions on the first
chromosome and none on the second or
third that have been important in the
evolutionary divergence between main and
alabama we know that these are three
peaks and not shoulders of one peak
because the two lateral peaks are
different in sign from the central one
it could be argued that what we are
seeing here is not a difference between
populations but since we drew two
individuals at random one from each
parent population what we're looking at
is polymorphism within populations so we
made a reciprocal cross between Alabama
and Maine and looked at that QTL map and
we got something entirely different that
is there were cutie cutie L in the first
chromosome but at the other end of the
first chromosome than here and there's
one on very prominent one on the second
chromosome here which is totally missing
here so this means that you're the
genetic the perception of the genetic
basis of the trait you're looking at
depends critically not only on the
population within the species you're
looking at but the individuals from
within that population that you choose
to evaluate genetic variation so our lab
has shown that the genetic mechanisms
underlying photo periodic response are
going to be far more complex than anyone
expected from knowledge of other
biological timing mechanisms and ie
circadian rhythms a genetic background
that is the genetic composition of the
rest of the individual or the rest of
the population has an all is essential
in evaluating the genetic architecture
underlying adaptive evolution that there
clearly is going to be gene gene
interaction that epistasis pleiotropy is
we now ask how do our genetic results to
date help us to interpret and predict
the impacts of climate change he's going
to return to the topic finally so let us
take the isotherms of eastern North
America from the Gulf of Mexico to the
Canadian border where each line denotes
a given temperature mean daily
temperature at that latitude and at that
time of year a couple of things emerge
from this graph first of all one
traverses very few isotherms in
mid-summer and a lot more isotherms in
midwinter so the climatic gradient of
eastern North America is primarily one
of winter cold not summer heat and hence
my question about vernalization and
chilly and the second thing to notice
suppose we take the developmental zero
of our organism at 15 degrees we concede
that the 15 degree isotherm temperatures
warmer than that are about 10 and a half
months long along the Gulf of Mexico in
less than three months long along the
Canadian border so that the climatic
gradient of eastern North America is not
only one of winter cold it's also one of
length of the growing season we now take
as a reference point chosen arbitrarily
we let a hundred and twenty years of
climate change take place and we say
this is what we expect the climate up
here to look like in a hundred and
twenty years of climate change in its
current rate what do we notice there has
been more than a doubling of the growing
season so that selection as Chris and I
alluded to earlier the selection is
working on the timing of seasonal
development not necessarily on the
direct effects of temperature because
warming winters promote an earlier onset
of spring later onset of winter longer
growing seasons
and therefore impose natural selection
on the timing of development
reproduction migration and dormancy how
does this happen here is a Norton a
northern locality with the same plot
indicating about 15 and three-quarters
hours of light per day climate warming
produces later winters which should
select for a shorter more southern like
critical photo period does this actually
happen are the responses of populations
in nature actually becoming more
southern like and the answer is yes they
are that we published this article in
2001 it was the first article to show
actual genetic change or evolutionary
response to climate change we wouldn't
have believed the data ourselves had we
not actually replicated the experiments
due to dumb stupid ignorant luck we had
determined critical photo period over
Geographic gradients to answer different
questions and I mean 30 years ago
climate warming was a non-issue so he
didn't design experiments to answer that
question we designed these experiments
to answer other questions we made a
collection over this gradient in 1972
and again in 1996 96 in red as you can
see there is a shift towards shorter
more southern like critical photo
periods over this twenty four year
period this shift is significant in
effect there is a year by latitude
interaction which is also significant
that means the slopes of these two lines
are different why do we expect that that
is because climate change is taking
place faster in the north than in the
south so we would expect to see a
greater response in the north than in
the south and that's exactly what we see
there is another problem with what
call then and now experiments and that
is you have to be sure that you are
imposing exactly the same conditions now
as you did back then and this experiment
has a built in control because we expect
little or no change in the climate in
Florida which is down here and hence if
we are recreating exactly the same
conditions these points should fall on
top of each other which they do for to
answer later questions unrelated to
climate change we made collections just
five years apart and used a much more
precise measurement of critical photo
period again there is a shift towards
shorter more southern like critical
photo periods and there is again a
significant year by latitude interaction
even with the smaller sample size so
this experiment repeats and we see that
there has been a genetic since we grew
them through two intervening generations
and critical photo period breeds true in
the lab this represents a genetic shift
actual evolution in nature that is
detectable over a five-year period this
is evolution on the hoof at breakneck
speed since a publication of our article
other articles have come out showing
genetic change in plant and animal
populations these data are hard to come
by people do not have data from 20-30
years ago particularly ones where they
can can factor out genetic from
phenotypic change all of these genetic
changes involve the timing of seasonal
development not reproduction not a
single one of them has shown a
difference in thermal optimum or thermal
tolerance and need I point out that all
of the bottom row here are hosts for
disease vectors that brings us to this
wonderful article that we
just came across and that is the
reproduction of deer herons and frogs
and the blood meals that are taken from
those animals and whether they are in a
reproductive state or not and there is a
remarkably close correlation between
blood feeding of mosquitoes and the
reproductive status of the hosts that is
the mosquitoes are attacking the mother
dear and fawns when they're distracted
with reproductive and developmental
processes they're biting chicks in the
nest and they're biting calling frogs so
climate change we've shown is affecting
the seasonality of insects birds and
mammals it's changing the optimal time
to do things then for a mosquito in his
change in the optimal time of year for
the mosquito to do things based strictly
on climate we didn't introduce the host
as I said why am i as a wimpy
non-binding mosquito but for the rest of
you in this room if you're working at
temperate latitudes there is going to be
not only selection on the optimal timing
of seasonal activities of the host and
optimal time for seasonal activities of
the mosquito but there's going to be
host by vector interaction in the
optimal time to do things so like we'd
like Chris and I would like to emphasize
the importance not only of host seasonal
timing and what it means to the to the
mosquitoes but therefore on vector by
host interaction and their ability to
spread diseases so today history tells
us what can happen the contemporary
distribution of vectors tells us that
history has the potential to repeat
itself ultimately the genetic background
of individuals and populations will
determine their evolutionary potential
to survive and reproduce in changing
environments climate change is
resulting an altered selection on
seasonal timing of vectors their hosts
and therefore vector hosts interaction
vectors may track the seasonal timing of
their hosts our host may shift
reproduction into more vulnerable
seasons animals are not glaciers light
rather than the direct effects of
temperature we become increasingly
important in determining the timing of
life history events has pathogens
vectors and their hosts move into and
expand in the temperate zone we'd like
to leave you with the following grim
message that all of these animals are
out there in eastern North America
they're waiting this is happening are we
ready for them thank you